au loin du centre denis pro un théâtre
ou des déplacés font la queue pour se
procurer quelques produits de première
nécessité cette famille a fui cravate
lorsque dans le dos basse
nous avons besoin de vêtements pour la
petite parce qu'elle grandit vite ses
vêtements sont trop petits nous n'avons
pas les moyens d'en acheter c'est pour
ça qu'on est venus ici pour trouver
quelque chose pour elle
parfois les déplacés arrivé à ni pro
depuis un moment se transforme sans
volontaire c'est le cas d'ivan qui sert
qu'à que repas chauds aux déplacés
fraîchement arrivé
je suis doublement réfugiés j'ai dû fuir
de miettes que pour aller à kharkhiv et
ensuite j'ai dû fuir karkhiv mais
j'espère bien y retourner
au restaurant sert chaque jour
gratuitement une centaine de repas à des
exilés dans leur propre pays souvent
déboussolés
nous n'avons pas d'argent je suis
handicapé depuis tchernobyl j'ai vécu
d'abord tchernobyl puis deux gars du
donbass je ne peux pas retourner chez
moi je n'ai plus de maison je ne peux
pas rejoindre ma famille soit en zone
occupée
je ne sais pas de quoi l'avenir sera
fait je veux juste l'apec pour tous rien
de plus
annie trop certains ne font que passer
comme cette famille qui a embarqué à la
hâte ce qu'elle a pu pour fuir la ville
de pau croft dans le donbass et gagner
le centre du pays
j'ai pris toute ma famille mon chien
le gouvernement nous a recommandé de
partir parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui va
se passer
ma mère est restée là bas
selon le maire de la ville 15 mille
déplacés affluent chaque jour admis pro
ils viennent du dombass de kharkiv de
marioupol qui choisissent de rester ou
de continuer leur chemin souvent ils ont
le sentiment d'avoir échappé au pire